i will call the
fiscal committee to order
and um folks we have new microphones
so um
to talk
it's on the right
to not talk we only have one button oh
you only i have two
oh okay
version
i don't know
anyhow if it's red it's live
and uh
you will also notice that um
you can hear through the
mic that's on
the speaker
so um
we are
moving forward with technology that
obviously i don't understand
so
if we could um
the first item on the agenda are the
minutes for
january 14th
2020.
um could i have a motion to accept
thank you thank you are there any
yeah gary daniels
okay
like i can just raise hands on this
right okay
all right if everybody would raise their
opposed
abstain
one
the next is the acceptance of the
could i have a motion to approve thank
you senator
second by senator daniels
seeing none all those in favor please
raise your hand
opposed
abstain one
okay
to fis022
and it's currently on the table
is that where it should remain or
do i have anyone that wants to take it
off
seeing none we will
move on
okay
we have
four items
that have been removed from the consent
calendar
under tab 8
22-077
and under tab 9
we have
okay
okay um
represent the earth for you
zero seven three
okay
um is the department available to
okay uh
miss rounds could could you hang on just
a second sure i'd like to make a motion
i would like someone to make a motion to
approve all of the other items on the
consent calendar
all those in favor raise your hand
opposed
okay consent calendar is approved except
for the items that we removed
so i'm sorry
go ahead thank you madam chair good
morning
um
and i appreciate the department's
information that it
sent over the other day the supplemental
information my question really is about
how how
can we
measure the success of the doorways
program beyond just saying
they've had contact 27 000 times
particularly in light of the fact that
overdose deaths are up sharply
in manchester 36
versus year ago and nashua 31
versus a year ago how do we
how do we know more than just
27 000 interactions is it the same
people different people where are they
from
would
do we have information that the
referrals are actually getting picked up
and the appointments
made
how how can we really understand that
this program
is
helping
so good morning
for the record i am katya foxx i am the
director of the division for behavioral
health and
in anticipation of your question we did
prepare quite a comprehensive response
which hopefully was shared with the full
committee
but
to your point and i
i know this is an area that we often get
questions on and we would love to be
able to give you a very
robust answer but we can tell you that
we have the doorway report
so
when we
provide those numbers of how many are
served on a monthly basis and then
cumulatively
those are the numbers of unique
individuals in that particular reporting
period
so when we say 27 000 it could be that
they're replicated but we're seeing um
roughly between 800 and a thousand per
month
um on and that's an on on a unique
identifier a unique uh visit person they
may have visited more than once
from a referral perspective we do have
the requirement through the federal
grant that we do
an assessment and those assessments are
done
upon initiation of the contact so this
is required for that federal funding
that we receive that is subject to this
matter this morning
and then there are required follow ups
at the six month period the 12-month
period and discharge what we're finding
and this has been a problem across the
country is being able to
be in touch with people throughout that
duration so at the six-month period and
12 as you get to 12 months it's harder
for follow-up because they may have
moved they may have moved on
they may have relapse they may be in
recovery and don't want to have that
contact
um and for a variety of reasons
were unable to have the robust data that
we would get if we had
a higher percentage of returns on those
follow-up assessments which are quite
lengthy
we have
continued to look at ways that we can
work with our quality unit on how we can
measure effectiveness of this particular
system
access was the number one
goal
of this
project in this part what has become a
program when we receive this so the
access appears to be working
by the numbers and
by the surveys that we've done however
we do know that we need a
really robust evaluation
and that is in the works and we'll be
procuring for that evaluation
shortly because that was never part of
the initial
funding
it was through this samsung-led
federal
survey that we need to do
with that without follow-up at the
individual level but we need a more
comprehensive assessment of whether this
system is working and again we have
secured the funding through some
supplemental block grant dollars and
we'll be looking at the efficacy
thank you
two quick follow-ups if i could
one is um
if if we re-implemented that closed-loop
referral kind of thing would that give
us the data on
following
the users across
sites and two
how
how is the doorways going to help
uh us not see drug overdose deaths that
are up over 30 percent in our
two biggest cities what else
do we need to be doing so we're not
losing
an increasing number of people
so i'll answer your second question
first in that
this action will allow us to move the
four million dollars among between class
lines to be able to purchase naloxone
naloxone and medicated assisted
treatment are
what have
prevented deaths we would have many more
deaths we have a huge increase in the
overdoses but we're finding the
effectiveness of having the lux uh
naloxone be
um
ubiquitous in the in the um areas so
that we want to continue that and we're
finding that uh the demand for naloxone
is high so that's what that four million
dollars will do in this item so we're
doing that i don't think the doorways
can solve the problem i think you as you
know
it's multi multi-faceted and it's
complex and it's only gotten worse as a
result of the pandemic
and so we're taking other steps so for
example
some of the
harm reduction the efforts under this is
not just to
purchase naloxone but to provide it to
hard to reach communities
which we find
in the larger areas
but again there's there's the whole
law enforcement side there's the
um individual family situations
and there is the housing the lack of
housing as an availability
and so we're just doing everything we
can using all the resources we have to
how
how or whether
the closed loop referral kind of thing
would supplement the information you
have on the doorways
so close loop referral would
is a very effective tool at being able
to have providers have the information
they need to treat somebody in a
holistic way
and so it also assures that when a
referral is made i think to your earlier
point how do we know what happens after
referrals made is there follow-up we
would know that as a as a closed-loop
referral
because there would be a report back and
the exchange of information with the
are there any other questions yes
thank you madam chair
thank you for your testimony today
is there any way of aggregating the cost
of doorways and associated programs
into a single dollar figure so we can
get an estimate of how much the system
i'm looking at you
i mean i think we have our funding
sources we know how much we've spent on
each program the state opioid response
grant has been in effect since 2018
the doorways open january 1st of 2019 we
have all of those costs
that we could provide
and and then the question becomes do you
want it holistically to include other
federal funds and other
um general funds that are were already
in place before the
state opioid response so it depends on
how vast you want it but we have all
those numbers
thank you madam chair i i leave it to
the pleasure of the committee i'd like
to know doorways but again if we know
what we had before and what we're doing
now that gives us a basis to start
comparing effectiveness in terms of
dollars spent
sure we can go right back to um i think
it was the fall of 2018 for the doorways
when we first contracted with them and
we can go right through up until now
miss rounds you agree
yes i was just asking her a question i
think that there's a chart that we um
created not that long ago that probably
would get out the answer okay okay i
think senator rosenwald's question about
the
effectiveness
is
is so important
because just giving
i know you use
i use narcan
out you know doesn't doesn't solve the
problem
it postpones the problem
and
most of us were hoping
is that with doorways that we would be
able to
you know
have a better handle on the uh
problems with uh drug overdose
so
okay no i mean that's that's just the
way it is
um are there any other questions or
comments one question yes thank you
madam chair um
maybe in the realm of hypothetical but
can you in any way
attempt to correlate the effects of
covid
uh and the impacting societal disruption
if you will to the spike
in these i don't know if you have the
capability but i'd be interested to know
whether this spike is a you know has
causation or correlation to covid or is
it something that's you know going on
i'm turning it off she's turning it on
sorry about that so um thank you senator
i think that there have been national
surveys and studies and indications um
when you
say correlation i think we can we can
make
some
assumptions about that and share that
information that we do have available
thank you
oh yes senator daniels thank you
could you share what the department is
doing to
prevent these things from happening
because i mean the information we got
said from from 2019 to the
to current it's been
relatively steady which means all the
money that we have thrown into this
really hasn't done anything in bringing
the numbers down
uh you're coming and you're asking for
an additional four million dollars for
naloxone
but that's indicative
of the fact that
you wouldn't need it
unless rate and less rates of incidences
were increasing so i'm interested in
knowing what you're doing to try to
get to the root of this
and
if there are obstacles to doing that
what are they
so thank you senator that's a great
opportunity to start talking about
prevention and all the prevention
efforts
when we talk about state opioid response
it's a categorical funding it's
specifically for opioids and now
stimulants and it's after
well after the fact when people are in
crisis and in need of these services
we have the governor's commission which
has made
a big prevention part of a big focus of
its work to which we
provide the contracts and go before gnc
with the governor's commission funding
to fund those programs so there are
multiple programs that are happening at
the preventative level
so i'd be happy to provide
a list or the information about the
prevention efforts that are happening
across the board
and not only with us but with the
yes go ahead by virtue of the fact that
the numbers don't seem to be coming down
would you say that the preventative
efforts were successful
so i think with prevention the problem
is we when we make an investment we
don't see an immediate return when you
give someone naloxone you see an
immediate return
but when you
invest in prevention we don't have the
it's the absence of
and so when we're asked
the increase or the steadiness of the
numbers of deaths from opioids we don't
have the number of those per what we
prevented in that in that time period so
i think it's hard to quantify and it's
hard for us to want to fund it and think
about it and invest in it because we
don't see that quick return on
investment
but we do believe that prevention
does make a difference
yes follow-up would you expect that uh
with the money that we put into
prevention that you should see the
numbers
yes
question
senator guida thank you madam chair
i'd be interested in knowing if if the
department or perhaps lba could
pull together the numbers
for under the broad categories of
prevention
treatment and interdiction
and that would give us a really good
representation of the balance of funding
towards these different efforts and
maybe there needs to be some work done
there
i think it also might be helpful
if um
we could get something from the
courts about how many
cases
what's their case load
because the things that we're talking
about
if the case load is going down
then i think we would know
that
you know prevention is working the
caseload is going up then
it we might not but i do think that you
can't
you can't separate
what dhhs is trying to do from what
the court system is trying to do
yes
thank you madam chair i have had
written inquiries from
several county attorneys and their staff
about what can we possibly do to
uh ease
the laws
i won't say legalize but change the
parameters because they are buried
under under drug cases and that's from
two separate counties
thank you
okay
um
seeing no further questions uh
could i have a motion please
and seconded by uh senator rosenwald
would you please
would the clerk please call the roller
okay
oh 073 eric votes yes
earth yes
leishman yes
representative lin yes
senator daniels
yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
twenty two zero seven three uh passes on
a vote of
ten to zero
we now turn to tab eight
twenty two
representative leitchman i believe you
had some questions on this uh yes thanks
and i
uh thanks for taking my question i want
to just thank you folks for
answering a few questions but it led me
to a question
excuse me would you move your microphone
a little closer
so thank you for taking my question so
it said in your response that you have a
contractor that provides a service and
there are about a hundred cases
that are under investigation and a
backlog of i think it said 860 roughly
now during the pandemic there was
certainly a severe food issue people
weren't getting food now
what happens when this investigative
unit goes out are they trying to recover
monies lost or to verify people that are
getting support should be getting
support
thank you for your question for the
record my name is karen hebert and i'm
the director for the division of
economic and housing stability
so just to clarify uh part of your
question
with respect to the special
investigations unit that is not a
contracted unit those are state
employees the contractor
is
for the system known as new heights
that maintains the eligibility programs
for processing those applications
including snap
so the consultant is actually the system
vendor for those which is the bulk of
the
expenditures for this item
so the special investigations unit works
to identify
whether or not there is you know they
make a determination with respect to
their findings on fraud investigations
whether someone really wasn't eligible
who may have
uh misled the department and some
respect with
regarding their eligibility
or were using the benefits when they
were no longer entitled to them for
example if they move out of state
they're required to report their address
to us so if they've moved out of state
and they are using the benefit in
another state without us being informed
that could be considered fraud
so the department would take steps to
try to recover
the funding with the means that it has
available to do so
so there are
a number of
special investigation unit
staff
who conduct these investigations for the
department
so this the funding is about seventeen
thousand dollars out of this item
that would go towards overtime
in order to try to catch up with that
backlog which was
created in part because of the pandemic
and an extraordinary number of referrals
that the unit received for fraud
investigations that were quite higher
than what we normally receive
just a further question if i could make
him chair yes thanks
so what's the success rate because
obviously a number of these people
probably don't have a lot
to offer financially so
is
is the unit successful in recouping some
of the losses or
are we spending a lot of money to chase
something we can't catch it is
successful in part i think that it
depends on the circumstances and if
you'd like i'd be more than happy to get
you a more precise percentage of the
success rate thank you thank you madam
chair
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
this is a
an existing unit in the department
did we budget
any money in the
house bill one
to make changes to new heights or
um is this the only changes we're making
to new heights i guess i'm asking
why do we only need this now and why
didn't the department need it during the
budget
the changes that are needed for the
system at this time
were predicated by an evaluation
conducted by the u.s department of
agriculture and findings that we
received regarding the need to change
the way we were documenting tracking and
reporting
these types of cases
so the changes are necessary in the
system to be able to meet
the uh requirements or recommendations
when did we get that evaluation
that is a good question i mean i guess
i'm going to say within the fourth the
budget was oh yes it's so the the the
evaluation would have been completed
within the last few months okay so
certainly not within time for the budget
thank you i would also just mention that
these are 100 federal arpa funds and
arpa funds were not budgeted in the
budget
senator guida thank you madam chair um
how many employees are in this
department division agency bureau
i believe it's five or six at this time
right how many cases are follow-up
yes thank you manager how many cases are
you are you are they prosecuting right
now
no i mean are they pursuing right
investigating right now sure so at the
moment there is a backlog of 866 cases
that need to be investigated or
completed with the investigation so some
of them have already started
typically there is an average of about a
hundred
cases pending at any given time so this
is quite an extraordinary amount
thank you you're welcome
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
senator guida moves to approve second
second by senator rosenwald
roll call zero seven seven
emery votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator morse yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator delasandro
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0
fis-22077
passes with a vote of
10 to zero
okay
and this is with the
governor's office for emergency relief
does someone
have a question
yes
good morning
good morning taylor caswell with uh
go ahead thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner
um
these are we currently having any funds
expended towards attracting folks to
the trades
in our schools whether it's by the ctes
or any other
agencies of government or otherwise do
you know
speaking for gopher and for my
department bea no uh not at this point
but i i imagine there may be other
follow up
so
thank you madam chair would you be
amenable to tabling this till we can
find out whether funds are being
expended
um
i mean that's obviously your decision
senator i think uh this program is
one is unique in the sense that it is uh
currently in operation
in uh in a half the form i suppose that
we would hope that we would see it
and it has proven to be quite successful
uh
in uh lieu of the fact that there if
there are other programs i'm not aware
of any that are operating at the success
yes follow it so
can you elucidate a little bit on the
success rate or you know in terms of
funds expended people moving into jobs
that wouldn't otherwise go on that way
or into training programs is there any
way you have any data on that uh well
what i could do is i could ask um john
nyan who is here today from the hampton
chamber who has been running the program
for the last several months or years uh
john
good morning and for the record my name
is john nyan
president of the hampton area chamber of
commerce
also the chair of the new hampshire
association of chamber executives
senator
good question
this program started if i may just give
you a little bit of background
uh this program started with a small ten
thousand dollar grant from the new
hampshire charitable foundation uh
nature school of mechanical trades and
went
kind of high school we put 10 kids
through this program
um and it was so successful because of
the
interest from the students to continue
with the training
we had a second grant from the
foundation of ten thousand dollars
we then expanded with the help of new
hampshire mechanical trades not wanting
to
add more dollars to their cost
they actually contributed in kind
services for the second program where we
then were able to expand
one high school to seven high schools
and from 10 students to 20 students
this program
that we're proposing would expand it
once again
not only for seacoast high schools but
for greater manchester high schools also
to be included since the new hampshire
school of mechanical trades has a second
location in manchester
the success rate so far
we have had close to 30 i believe it was
29 students that actually completed the
program
and right now at the new hampshire
school of mechanical trades we have 10
that have gone on to extend
training in a particular trade be it
plumbing electrical
hvac oil and heating so it's been a
success
and one of the things about this this
grant application if you if i may
is that we have now connected with
apprenticeship new hampshire
to where we'll be working with them as a
follow-up once the
student goes through this program they
will then have the opportunity and
benefit to go into an apprenticeship
program
um and and this this grant application
would support that
follow up
yes go ahead thank you madam chair so i
heard you say that this is taking care
of seacoast and manchester
that is correct would it be possible to
dedicate some of these funds to the more
rural areas
where
i can tell you with my house undergoing
some renovations there is a desperate
need
for and i would like to see some of you
some comment on that
senator we we would love to expand this
program at this point right now there
are
only two locations from the new
hampshire school of mechanical trades i
know that there has been discussion
which i ca i can't
tell you exactly what the details are of
them expanding uh to the north country
and adding a third
location but but i think it's important
to to note that this particular
concept
we could do anywhere in the state if we
and so i would presume by that you mean
some sort of a permanent structure
that's correct okay
yeah the um there are there are some
programs not mechanical trades programs
that are actually taking place in
different high schools
um but in this case with mechanical
school of trades they have not only
classroom facilities but actually
workshops where the uh the young adults
can actually
training real quickly on that subject uh
this uh program there are other partners
involved with it the chambers being one
of them and they have demonstrated at
least in this instance a real aptitude
to get this program up and running uh we
have committed to continue to working
with them uh to find uh other locations
to if this program is as successful as
we expect it to be uh to grow this
program statewide i mean that would be
my goal with this because uh this is uh
an area that we really need to focus on
for reasons similar to what your
you have a follow-up or are you okay
thank you
we we're we're creating cte centers all
around the state and we're enhancing
them and proving them all the time
why isn't there some kind of a
synergistic relationship between these
entities that we're creating and we're
spending millions and millions of
dollars to do that just think of what
we're doing in hudson right now with the
addition to the school but why isn't
there a relationship you got a natural
setting you talked about a bricks and
mortar the bricks and mortars are there
the question is
um
communication is there good
communication there between the system
the school systems that are that that
are operating these cte centers i mean
that's why all this money is being spent
and we're we're we're programmed to keep
spending this money this is an ongoing
it's an ongoing situation
and you know we're bonding and we're
spending this money and it seems to me
that
it must not be working well if indeed
you have to do something like this and
you're looking for places to go
tell me tell me why there isn't a
cooperative situation
there is actually senator and i know art
for speaking for my department we have
very good relationship with the cte
centers
across the state
when i spoke to senator guida about how
we're looking at ways to be able to
expand this program beyond just the
manchester and seacoast areas into rural
schools with cte programs that have
exactly these types of programs i think
that is our next target rather than
building something new that would be
seeing no oh did you know the question
i'll move the item all right thank you
senator guida
do i have a second
gotta turn on zero eight zero
clerk votes yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes representative lynn
yes senator daniels yes senator morris
yes senator gaiden yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
22-080 uh passes on a vote of 10-0
we will now turn to tab 9
fis22081
okay
um
i think we have some uh
questions for
good morning
there we go
hi charlie arlinghaus the commissioner
of administrative
services thank you for joining us thanks
for having me yeah of course
um
are there questions
that anyone would like to ask
okay uh
yes uh thank you madam chair jolly
always a pleasure to see you
uh
i i've looked at the report i've looked
at the vacancy report uh commissioner
and
as as i look at it and i look at the
percentages in the departments
well
and uh
how is this going to
enhance your ability i've sponsored a
piece of legislation for you to do some
things with with with recruitment but it
seems to me our problem now is
recruitment and retention
we have a dual problem and when i look
at the numbers we've got almost 2 000
vacancies in state government
spread
throughout
all of all of our departments
so
how is this going to be effective
in supporting
what what we need is that recruitment
policy i guess
so to put it in context for for
everybody um the current vacancy rate in
state government is about 18 18 of
authorized positions are not filled
right now
that's that's one of those things right
every department has some positions they
just don't fill because if we don't fill
if we fill them we can't meet the lapse
requirement
you're counting on us to keep them to
maintain a very healthy vacancy rate
and uh if if state vacancy rates gets
get below about 10 percent
we can't function as state government
because they're too low
right and you you've budgeted them to be
higher than that
um but 18 is is really remarkably high
it's ticking down a little bit i'll make
that i'll make that note that in the
first year of a budget vacancy rates
tend to be higher legislatures budgets
authorize lots of new positions and they
take a while to fill so they tend to be
higher in the first year lower in the
second year
vacancy rates in state government tend
to be higher when it's a good economy
for job seekers this is a very good
economy for job seekers it's a wonderful
economy for job seekers because there
are lots more positions and there are
people looking for them so state
government in those circumstances tends
to be a little um a little harder to
come by we tend to be less nimble than
other places um there are a lot of very
attractive things about state service
notably the benefits and there are a lot
of things that are a little less
attractive in a vibrant economy notably
the wages
and so
some of that is to be understood
part of what goes on though is that when
the vacancy rates are relatively high is
that
the people in charge of hiring or the
people who aren't getting their work
done because they don't have people
hired and when you're not getting your
work done because you don't have
somebody hired it's because you're
taking on something else and you don't
want to take time out from the work that
you're doing because you don't have
somebody to hire somebody that you don't
have and it's sort of this vicious
circle um in addition to that there are
a bunch of areas we've heard from a
bunch of agencies who've said
we need help recruiting so the division
of personnel came up with this plan
we're going to hire three people whose
job is to do nothing but recruit and
we're going to start by focusing on the
places that are particularly hard to
hire for
and we we we hope it's a pilot program
and we hope it's going to work real well
for the question yes please
charlie i i agree with the premise i
think it's a good one and i'd like to
see it work out thank you
but over the course of these fiscal
committee meetings we have authorized an
additional 83 positions
that's so far
and and we're authorizing more positions
here
when when when are we going to see the
results of the recruitment and retention
policies
that bring state government to the point
where we're actually functioning
at
and i never i i can never believe it's
at total capacity sure but we're we're
addressing
the needs of state government and i know
corrections is here and
i've talked to them but indeed if these
problems
continue
our ability to function
is seriously affected very seriously
affected
so some something's got to happen and
i i hope these things are working but
but indeed as i look at them i i just
can't see that positive movement charlie
and i hope it occurs
there's not significant positive
movement and and i don't want to pretend
that there's going to be dramatic
movement in any case
our our task really is to do a lot of
little things and to try to improve the
situation um state government is always
going to be fuller in a bad economy and
emptier in a in a good economy that's
that's that's the nature of the beast
but our our task is to is to work with
agencies to help them fill their highest
priorities first and to get there um
you know i mean i i don't know you know
you think about you think about arpa and
things like that there's a lot of
construction money floating around
and someone said we should build this
and build this and build this which is
all a great idea and and and i speak for
my department we're very much in favor
of building
because we do buildings and everything's
kind of a mess
um
but you need people to do it and you
know uh
somebody's having worked under his or
her house i forgot who i wasn't paying
that much not paying as much attention
as i should have um
but you know we've all experienced that
at some point you want somebody to come
fix the steps and there aren't that many
bricklayers around
so we're going to do everything we can
to make a difference this is one thing
that's going to make some difference
but agencies
ultimately it's at agencies and and we
uh senator morris
charlie there's a 50 million dollar item
that i think you just talked yourself
out of that i've been looking at for
fixing buildings so
yeah and i can find a use for it so
don't worry
um
can lba or charlie
tell us what for seven months this 19
vacancy equates to and then the other
end of that question is because i i see
it happening
every time we come here how much of that
think charlie can comment on the um
number of positions that are vacant as
far as
i'm looking for
other lines um
that will take some time we can work
with das to see what we can
find anything that's come before you
anything that's gone before gnc with the
transfer
from state personnel lines be it to
overtime or something else
we'll try to figure out a way to track
that yeah i just bring it up because i
know the senator's met with corrections
i'm meeting with corrections um
25 vacancy
it's a lot of money
and we're transferring it into overtime
which i understand we've done this every
year i've been here several times a year
but
there's a reality of these dollars what
are they
and i don't think they total the laps
dollars i think they far exceed it so
as we're swimming in money
and i know the chair from the house the
chair from the senate are going to
caution everybody stop spending
because i think it's crazy that we're
having a second budget year but i really
do think beyond the budget numbers that
you've put out in the public
there's a huge lapse here
and just in labor i mean and
what is being what's happening
with that i think we ought to keep our
hands on because
it's real easy to transfer out of the
classified lines to somewhere else and
fiscal gets to approve that and
you know that's fine but it's spending
and i think we ought to
be careful there so
um anyhow just
i'll just note that
there are a lot of agencies um where you
can't transfer out of class 10. there
are a few large agencies where you can
but they are the exception of the rules
so in most cases
for your typical agency that money is
going to have to lapse
but when you take a department like
corrections that's all state funded
for the most part you when you transfer
that out to overtime lines it's
significant number one
i don't know how we ever solved the
problem so we can talk about it till the
cows come in you know the reality is
it's a good starting job people go in
and then they transfer to police
departments throughout the state and
you know we're just keep doing that same
game but i mean the overtime's
significant and i think we
if that's how we solve the problem great
but i'm not sure that they agree that
that's great so
but anyhow there's a lot of money
involved here i think it's far exceeds
that lapse that you mentioned charlie
and uh that's what i'd like to find out
i'm going to avoid any comment on
senator guy do you have a question
thank you madam chair so
if i heard you correctly
when the economy is good
historically the state suffers in its
employment numbers
yeah all right
second thing i think i heard you say was
that
employees leave because of
better wages on the outside and they
come here because of benefits on the
inside so to speak correct
well i i i think our biggest attraction
you know i've been sitting through i'd
do all the final interviews in our
department lately and um
i'd say 50 of the people i talked to
when i said why are you interested they
say wages
it's particularly true at the lower
levels
and it's particularly true of older
workers
25 year olds don't tend not to care
about wages and 55 year olds 10 or
benefits and 55 year olds do
so for obvious reasons
so the question is if we add three more
personnel but we haven't changed the
environment that produces this shortfall
are we really helping anything
well i
i don't want to be fatalistic i i think
it's one of the it's something to say
that you know there are times when it's
very difficult to hire but that doesn't
mean you don't you don't try and it you
know think of a business trying to work
its way through a recession
um
you know my mom was in real estate in
detroit in the during the last couple of
recessions which is sort of a
theoretical activity more than an actual
one and you don't stop trying to sell
houses you're gonna sell fewer but if
you stop trying you're gonna sell two
and if you if you keep trying you may
sell four where you wish you sold eight
but you'd rather sell more so it's one
of the things that we do we try what we
can to do to hire and i think everything
we do helps and in a particularly bad
situation
um you know if the vacancy rate were two
percent
three percent and i came to you and said
we want to hire recruiters you should
send me send me off with a flea in my
ear
and um but it's not it's it's you know
17.8 among classified workers or
whatever the number is and uh and you
should say
you know what are we doing
and you know departments say to us all
the time what can you do to help we need
to do something and so this is this is
something it's not everything but it's
something
senate
follow-up oh okay
follow up so final question
so these
positions
would be utilized to recruit throughout
state government yes okay thank you
senator rosenwald you had a question
thank you madam chair i'm just
curious given the vacancy rate
that you don't have
current office space or furniture but
you have to acquire more
[Music]
well
as a testament to representative ober
who i understand isn't here on this
committee anymore but
um she sort of hounded in us anytime you
ask for a position make sure that you're
that you ask for everything that goes
along with it in this in this particular
case there's the
uh the vacancy rate um at the division
of personnel is not high i think it may
be close to zero and so we would need
desks
in that case i mean there are desks in
and around state government although
realistically what a lot of agencies do
is slowly replace their
um world war ii surplus desks
um which i'm fond of but not everybody
is
senator mars well i just want to put in
a plug that you have to get creative
because we approved 15 million dollars
to help with drf beds
and building them in epping and i know
throughout that whole process we told
the hospital they have to bring
employees from other parts of the
country to get that up and running
that's one of the reasons we put that
pitch together and i think things like
that are happening throughout government
and you know as we go to the executive
council with approval on that there was
a lot of thought that went into how do
we get a company to come in and bring
jobs to new hampshire to help solve a
problem that we know we have so i think
that's we're doing that and i don't i
think any business
is competing with us for 19
i mean you know right now in vacancy
rates um and that and that's no reason
to go and do some kind of study to tell
me that you have to raise the rates in
government because the other side is
going to raise their rates right when
you do it so i think there's a balance
here we'll figure it out but just keep
fighting i mean i think people want
these jobs and we should just keep
promoting them so
senator
daniels thank you commissioner you
mentioned uh that the new positions
would focus on three particular areas
could you identify those areas
the the i'm gonna have to read the item
you know we have issues with
let me let me back up a step
um
what we need to focus on is anywhere in
state government where we have
difficulty hiring people there's some
very obvious ones that people talk about
all the time there are a lot of health
care professions where we have
difficulty maintaining a workforce
there are you know i think every fiscal
meeting i've been to
somebody's talking about earth nurses
right and that's an obvious thing that
everyone's aware of we want to help to
the extent that we can in that area but
what we really need to do is to talk to
um
agencies about worker worker classes
where there are uh where there are large
vacancies and whether or not we can help
they're going to be some areas where
someone says listen i got an issue with
pharmacists and you're not going to help
me with that i have a different plan for
that there's going to be somebody else
who says i have an issue here you are
going to help me with that so the first
thing we're actually going to do it's
not really about specific areas like
we're not going to do this we're not
going to do that it's about identifying
the areas where we can add the most
value immediately and the the place we
start with that is vacancies and some of
them you know about some of them you
don't right i have 40 vacancy rate among
building service workers
which you know i think we're the only
people we're not the only people we have
the most building service workers
building service workers used to be
called cleaners
and they're wonderful people the last
person i talk to every single day
is beth who cleans the
first floor and then some of the annex
and
you know god bless her she's been here a
long time but um very few people it's
not it's not an attractive job and
exactly how we change the vacancy rate
from 40
because you know
the state state workforce is a great
thing but um it's not a lot to say about
cleaning toilets it's just not the
number one on anybody's list so so it's
not really about areas it's about
vacancies
if i call if i recall correctly
uh i believe in the budget the the house
had put in
a an amendment that said that hhs would
have no more than 3 000 positions
currently as i look at the vacant
positions and and the positions there
are currently 3249
positions
so as you're out there looking for hhs
personnel
knowing that you can't go more than
three thousand
how do you know
where to look
because well you we would not in a case
like that we work with the agency on on
on their greatest needs and and and
trust them to know
my sense is that the
department of health and human services
has a better handle on its budget than i
do
and can keep me out of trouble
i guess my point is you're hiring three
people to go out
and look for for specific things
right now there appear to be more
positions
in hhs than were authorized by the
legislature so it would be
uh
somebody's duty to to instruct
these three individuals just where
they're going to be looking for
help well
it's something we would work on with
with frankly with any department about
you know what are your what are your
needs where are you actually going to
hire people and and frankly on some
basic level a department will figure out
whether they can or can't
um in that sense and and i don't want to
get into whether they have enough for
too many or that's something i'll i'll
promise to talk to karen about
thank you
are there any further questions
i do have one
uh as you know mr arlinghaus we had
suggested that you try to
go out to hire a head hunting firm if
that's the right term
and i believe your answer was you wanted
to try this first and then you'd come
back
to fiscal with a change
so
how long
are we supposed to let you
do this
well i i would say um you know given
that given that
bidding and hiring a hench hunter firm
would take uh you know three to six
months at least
um
give me three months to see if i can
hire anybody
if i can't the distinction right is that
if i can hire somebody then we don't
need a firm to do this we don't need to
to you know overpay a consultant
if i can't hire anybody then we might
need to overpay a consultant
there are all kinds of problems with
having a consultant do this related to
access to the system
we can give we can give state employees
access to the system in a way that we
can't consultants without jumping
through a whole lot of hoops and and
um
dennis goulet getting mad at us and
while not letting us do it actually um
so i think that ideally we would like to
not hire not hire a consultant for this
i think it's tailor-made for people
and i
my director personnel tells me that she
feels very very confident or that we
can hire for this position and i would
anticipate um
you know we would post immediately and
and i'll be able to let you know in a
month whether we've filled them or not
so that would be my hope so give me a
month of month or month and a half to
hire and then give me three months to
tell you if it's working okay as long as
you don't poach from another
organization
okay you got that i uh you got that i
can't promise that yeah we post a
position people apply and
oh yeah the 13th amendment prohibits me
from telling them that i can't yeah well
filling your position just creates
another position it's i mean i
i absolutely get that we have that issue
all the time we we you know we hire and
and oh they're coming from employment
security and i said that because i'm
pretty sure george isn't here but um
that uh and they're like yeah what am i
supposed to do now and well you steal
somebody from from taylor and then you
just go like that and but we're we're
there's a lot of churn inside state
government which is actually nice for
people people like to be able to advance
within the state but then we also get we
do get a decent number of people coming
in from outside too
okay
uh
are there any further questions yes
representative leishman i'll move the
item if you're ready madam chair i'm
ready
will the clerk call the rule
okay we're all on zero eight one
uh court votes yes representative erf
yes representative leishman yes
representative lin
yes
senator daniels yes senator morris yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger uh yes
madam chair the vote is 10 to 0.
fis22081
passes 10 to 0.
and this is a light item right now
or not
all right um
expend money from prior year carryover
forward balance for the 911 system
seeing none could i have a motion
thank you senator
do i have a second second
thank you representative lynn
seeing no
further discussion
uh with the clerk call the roll
roll calling zero seven five
clerk boats yes representative irf yes
representative
yes representative lynn yes senator
daniels yes senator morris
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representative umberger yes
madam sure the vote is 10-0
thank you fis
passes on a vote of 10 to 0.
under tab 11
are there any questions
for d.o.t
seeing none could i have a
uh okay thank you senator d'alessandro
second
representative leishman
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call zero five seven
clerk votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
yes senator morris yes senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is ten to zero
okay on a vote of ten to zero
fis
twenty two zero five seven passes
now turn to tab 12
just to comment madam chair the
or
this goes into mike's list that he's
keeping on how much money the house is
spending and how much money the senate
is spending
this is a normal process i get it um i
think it's a good process for any
conceptual idea that the house is going
to send the senate on 100 million
but
i think it's uh
we need to keep this in mind because we
do this every year and it's spending so
we need to understand that
thank you senator
uh are there any further questions or
comments
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
move the item
thank you
you ready
well the clerk please call the roll
roll call on zero five nine clerk focus
yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes representing
glenn yes
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair the vote is 10 to 0.
fis 22059
passes on a vote of 10 to 0. now we turn
which is
fis-22060
department of corrections
wanting to transfer
7 million plus in general funds
among
various accounts
yeah
my
i've met with corrections and
asked corrections to uh
come up maybe
let's let's address their their
situation because as senator morris is
pointing out we we've been doing this
every year that i've been on the fiscal
committee for a long long period of time
but when you look at the vacancy rate
uh at corrections
the rate the the the vacancy rate is
extremely high
uh they've used
the national guard in the kitchen
to help out and we have to pay back
the national guard we're gonna use our
funds i think to pay back 500 000 to the
national guard
the overtime
is
as as it is here it's it's going to
reach 15 million
maybe more i'm not sure
but think about the second year of the
biennium if we don't make those two so
just a q if i meant a question to the to
the group i i understand you do a
magnificent job at maintaining
what we have and i credit you for that
i've been involved with corrections for
most of the time i've been in state
government
the pro the problem that we face now i
think is exacerbated
because
we just can't find people to fill these
corrections jobs
the overtime is uh
unbelievable and
where do we go i mean
there's got to be a solution out there
because
look at these transfers they take place
from authorized positions authorized
benefits
it would move so
we always we're always talking about the
laps well
there's never any lapse from corrections
right there's no lapse there
but but indeed
that this is a this is a problem
a very significant problem that that
really has to be dealt with
can anyone argue with that
it's it's i understand
the the
the
the argument is what's the solution yeah
i i agree i agree thank you thank you
madam chair yes
to the department
you know uh
what is that what is our game plan here
and um
i think we've made
changes about standards and training
right
in a very quick fashion when it comes to
taking these people so
the question is do we have a game plan
going forward that could address this
madam chair and thank you senator
d'alessandro for
sharing all of that information i hope
that the committee did receive the
activities within the department that we
have
engaged in over the last several years
to be unique and within the authority of
law that we have to both recruit and
work to retain our employees that we
have and in the resource materials that
i've sent forward
we were making what i would call strides
until coveted 19 hit our institution and
even in the first what i would call full
year 2020 we did better than i thought
we were going to do i'll tell you that
second this past second year of working
in corrections
changing our mitigation strategies we
lost a lot of tenured people because
they were simply tired and then on top
of then i'll quote your term poaching
we have a unique
law enforcement branch of the justice
system our employees work day in day out
one-on-one with people with felonies
bottom line in a very i'll talk about
new hampshire state prison for men old
institution so when we're training
people that their first line of defense
are their verbal de-escalation skills
and nationally we're saying that police
in the community need to improve their
verbal de-escalation skills
the corrections employees with
you know call it two three years
experience are very attractive
candidates and then the commensurate
equity in wages we pay about ten
thousand dollars less to a starting
corrections officer that's fully
certified than they do and they pay ten
thousand dollars more in municipal
policing and a state trooper who uh
state troopers are struggling as well to
recruit people are waiving a lot of
their i'll defer to them but in the
discussions i've had with them waiving
some of their minimum qualifications for
physically able
psychologically screened candidates
so law enforcement in general has faced
a hit so when we look at corrections and
i thank the legislature for letting us
use the transfer strategy of using
vacancies because it is the vacancies
that are resulting in the overtime to
move to overtime
because it sends a message to the people
working in corrections today that none
of us have given up to provide them the
resources they need not to work the
intense overtime hours and the last two
years kova 19 has been the reason we've
leaned on the national guard because on
top of the vacancies people were
legitimately sick and so i had
individuals who were corrections
officers out of the work environment to
the tune of maybe 45 or more in a day on
top of our vacancies just fully
exacerbated the situation
so part of what we've done uniquely is
we literally started an introductions to
corrections course at the berlin high
school we had seven participants in the
first class and now we've had a maximum
capacity in the second class we're
offering so we're going to look to
teaching people what corrections
literally is that we're not guards we're
not watching that table we're correcting
people and changing a pattern of
behavior we are one-on-one working with
individuals with who are committed in
many instances egregious crimes and are
also struggling with mental health and
substance use disorder and they need the
support of strong
people day in and day out to correct
patterns of behavior so
i thank you for
asking that question i think it's
important that this is a profession
worth
continuing to fight for but there are
some equities that the agency's trying
to resolve and we will need the
legislators support so that we're not
training fully qualified people who are
literally going to another branch of
state government to make ten thousand
thank you uh representative
sorry senator guida thank you madam
chair commissioner good to see you nice
to see you um
when a
corrections officer newly trained comes
out of the police academy
it comes over to you is there any
contractual requirement that they remain
for a period of time
and is that a possibility that could be
implemented i don't know contracts and
so forth
uh senator grant that's a great question
there's no contractual relationship
there like any other state employee as
you heard commissioner earling how
someone can recruit them for another
opportunity that they certify for i will
tell you i've seen a few other states
that do require i'll call it a tenure in
corrections before they can go work in a
certified police occupation and i i
think i would have my other law
enforcement partners telling you don't
do that to me but that's been some of
regardless of the other law enforcement
agencies we're here to deal with
corrections problems and so would this
be something that would be implementable
under your uh leadership uh senator
guide i think we would have to put
forward a legislative change and see
what the pallet of the legislature was
but i think it's possible
are there any further questions
yes representative leishman
thanks thanks madam chair
and thanks commissioner good to see you
just a follow-up to representative
geider's question we've heard of
industry providing some sort of
help towards education like a financial
benefit and then that individual has to
sign some kind of agreement with that
employer to stay for a certain period of
time would that be something worth
the legislature looking at
represented bleachman i i think that's
an excellent question again i had
suggested
again talking about state employee
vacancies before bargaining they had
asked me what do you think commissioner
and i said well what i'm hearing from my
staff is if we did something in the
education realm that people would stay
on longer but they're going and
advancing their career someplace else so
it's another i'll call it carrot or
attraction to come work for corrections
i have one
um
is the vacancy rate
higher at the men's prison than the
women's prison
as of today madam chair i think they're
almost equitable tell you that since uh
submitting the information our security
vacancy rate is 33 percent that's the
highest i've ever seen it
and we have some promising new
candidates coming uh but it's again with
that type of vacancy rate we're going to
take a long time to play catch-up
okay thank you and i i do want to give
one shout out senator morris i have not
come back for more medical money in
several years
[Laughter]
it's not a promise but i do want to
recognize that
yes
that's because of the terrific job she
did when we were doing the budget when
we talked about dealing with medical
costs how we could reduce medical costs
so i give her kudos for that uh we gave
her an assignment
when the finance committee was meeting
and she fulfilled it so
there's charlie yelling house we ought
to give a bonus on that one
i'm not quitting on this one either
so uh senator d'alessandro is that a
motion
thank you second seconded by senator
gaida are there any further questions
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
roll call protocol one zero six zero
clerk votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
yes senator morse yes senator gaiden yes
senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yeah
representative umberger yes
madam chair of the vote is 10-0
a vote of 10 to 0 fis 22-060
passes
okay we now turn to item
tab 14
and the these are the um
the late items
um
fis22082
is a request from the
department of natural and cultural
resources
seeing none could i have a motion please
thank you
senator rosenwald
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call in zero eight two clerk votes
yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
yes senator morse
senator gaida
yes senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes senator umberger i mean
sorry representative
i was on a roll yeah i could tell
although yes thank you
madam chair the vote is 10-0
thank you
fis
passes on a vote of 10 to 0.
now turn to
fis22083
and this is a request from the
representative leishman
thanks uh karen good to see you as well
uh
the request you have for six positions
now when you folks appeared before us i
believe back in october
on the 22nd
you mentioned that
in all likelihood the services to run
hampstead would be contracted
so i was a little surprised to see the
number of positions
and the cost for the positions in this
request could you explain
the need now
in the response that
you provided to some of our questions
you did say it was going to be similar
to the existing state hospital contract
so
could you explain how those two line up
sure so i i believe that the
commissioner did testify that it was
always our intention to keep senior
leadership as state employees
it offers the state a lot more control
over the facility to have the senior
leadership be state employees
the salary levels are in line with the
salaries that are paid to current new
hampshire hospital executive executives
and department executives
so that is where those salary amounts
are coming from there is legislation in
place to create unclassified positions
and those unclassified positions will go
through the corn ferry process to
receive the final salaries so the these
positions are essentially temporary so
that we can hire
the people into them and then they will
be transferred to uh permanent
unclassified positions later
the other piece which i um mentioned in
i meant to mention in my answer i may
have forgotten
the revenue cycle team will also be
state employees but those will be
classified employees so you will see
those come through in the operating
budget when i bring that forward to the
committee
revenue cycle being the employees that
are working with the insurance companies
collecting
the funds and depositing them because
those revenues will be state revenues
so there there is a a handful of state
employees that um will be part of
operating hampstead
further question ma'am chair yes
so i went back and looked at the minutes
from the october 22nd meeting
i just want to read a portion i believe
this was a
commissioner shibanette's response to
representative edward's concern about
the staffing issue of the hospital
so it go she goes on to say do the some
staffing issues
they have not been able to expand their
services meeting hampstead hospital i
assume yes our goal is again to purchase
hampstead in contract with a third party
to assist in running it
so
i guess i'm concerned with the number of
positions you're requesting i could see
like a contract officer
someone to oversee the running but
six positions which include senior
management to run a facility that right
now has only 45
individuals under their care
so i i think that uh not to be nuanced
but her response was assist in running
the facility so i think that that
may not have been
the most direct way to say that there
would be state employees there but i i
don't think that that
ruled out that there would be state
employees there
um i think as far as the number of beds
we've made it very clear that our intent
is to expand the number of beds as
quickly as we possibly can and this is a
24-hour facility so it certainly
requires a number of executives it's a
you know right now a ten tens of
millions of dollars business so it
requires a cfo it requires accounting
staff um
i i think that these positions are
absolutely required to run this facility
i don't have any further madam chair but
thank you
are there
senator rosenwald
thank you
we got a report from administrative
services about the vacancy rates
and new hampshire hospital has a 26
percent vacancy rate
the bulk of which are over 90 days
vacant
so
how realistic
is it that you can
hire all the staff you're going to need
for hampstead when we
haven't been able to at the state
hospital
yes thank you so much for the question
senator my name is marissa henn i'm an
associate commissioner
and i think one of the things that's
important to consider here is how much
of a transformation is really occurring
at hampstead this is not um
hampstead has served a critical role in
partnership with the state in caring for
children it has done a fantastic job
the future is going to be so much more
comprehensive in terms of what we will
be able to offer
youth adolescents across the state
including standing up the first ever
psychiatric residential treatment
facility filling a huge gap in the
continuum of services so
it's not going to be easy um hiring is
not easy right now but what we believe
is that this will be an attractive place
for
people to come work because they will be
part of of what the governor himself has
said is and the commissioner as well is
really a a state-of-the-art
center of excellence
ultimately and so i think that's part of
it is attracting people based on the
ways in which this is um this is a
change in status quo and a part of a our
larger transformation i think the second
thing is that bringing in a vendor who
has the capabilities the recruitment
skills um the national linkages even to
be able to attract people in a way that
has not been possible previously we're
seeing that right now with the temporary
staff that you all approve funding for
that has not been easy to bring in that
strike team to hampstead but we're doing
it we're effectively opening more beds
the last several weeks
thanks to the ability of a national
vendor to extend its reach in bringing
are there further questions senator
morris
just to be clear we're going to create a
management team
and we're hiring a vendor
correct
but there these positions will not be
representative lynn yeah i think i'm i'm
a little bit confused i wonder if you
could just explain uh
for us
the analogy i think you said at the
beginning in response to representative
leachman's question um you drew an
analogy to the state hospital so i
wonder if you could
could you just explain for example
how many at in the in the top management
of the state hospital how many of those
people are state employees and then what
percentage of the people under them are
not state employees and compare that or
contrast that with
what you envision for
hampstead hospital
so it's it's definitely not a perfect
comparison for a number of reasons but
the executive team is similar at new
hampshire hospital there's a ceo there's
a ceo there's a cfo all of those things
exist at new hampshire hospital and they
are state employees they are
unclassified
state employees
the
the staff at new hampshire hospital
there there of course is the contract
with dartmouth that provides some of the
clinical staff but many of the nurses at
new hampshire hospital are state
employees
with the contract at hampstead we
anticipate that all of the nursing staff
will be contracted through the
contractor so
there are definitely less anticipated
state employees at hampstead
percentage-wise than there are at new
hampshire hospital
okay
follow-up and can i just ask is there is
there a plan
sort of for over the longer term
that um as
uh
people that are now contract or people
that are envisioned to be contracted
employees at hampstead hospital as
as they sort of turn over that those
people would be replaced with state
employees
no so right now um the in the
commissioner has uh
um
informed gmc of this as well our plan is
to bring forward a contract a two-year
contract
that it will be sole source because we
need to move so quickly as we close on
this facility
during those two years we will evaluate
what
what the best model will be and have
time to issue an rfp and all of those
things so it won't happen
rolling throughout those two years when
we get
through those two years there will be a
new you know a potential a new model or
the current model will continue
thank you thank you senator daniels
thank you is it your intent that the
executive team that you hire is going to
be ongoing operating costs
yes
okay
follow up
yet your request is that you're going to
be using opera
funds which are one-time funds yes do
you find that a prudent way to use
one-time money for ongoing costs
so
i think that some of this is one time in
the sense that
we may hire them uh you know just prior
to acquisition
um you know we know that the purchase
and sales is in place we may want to get
some of those people on board and and
moving things along as we come to closer
to close
um and we will be presenting an
operating budget that will fund those
positions as unclassified positions
um and also we'll likely use arpa funds
unless there was a bill in the
legislature to appropriate general funds
so i i think that the operating budget
potentially does include some small
amount of operating funds until we move
into the budgeting process for
i always have to think of the fiscal
years in my head we're currently in 22
are there further questions uh senator
guida thank you madam chair thank you
karen
so if i'm hearing correctly we're
establishing a management team that that
is unclassified
yes
for
the indefinite future of the hospital
and that the vendor to whom refers
basically an employment agency that will
provide the staff
would that be an appropriate
characterization
i don't think that that's a
the right characterization the the
vendor certainly will be doing daily
operating of the hospital as well they
will just be doing it in conjunction
with the management team so it's not
like they're just providing a staff and
these people will
supervise all of them that it's it's not
quite like that there would certainly be
supervisors within the contracting you
know within the contractor that's that's
managing the hospital as well it's just
okay are there any other questions yeah
may i just yes can you can you give i
mean this i have to say this seems like
a really
strange for lack of a better term way to
operate this in the sense that i i mean
real potential for conflict between
these the these sort of chiefs
you know very high level people that
you're proposing to hire that are
employees of the state and then
this
this um
the rest of the universe of employees
being under subject to a contract
that there would be
great potential for con for conflicts
between
the state employee directors and the
people that are under contract and i'm
wondering if you could just give us
can you give us some exam it's and it
sounds like from what you said earlier
that the state hospital really is a
different
you know you may have a few contract the
contract with dartmouth et cetera but
most of the employee the the lower level
employees there are state employees so
i'm wondering if you could give us an
example of
other places in
state government
that are operated like this where
there's a
you know uh
the the top people are sort of state
employees and then they but everybody
else is kind of
uh
independent contractors are subject to
a contract
so i'm going to back up and i'll answer
your question along the way to give you
some perspective on why we're
structuring it this way
the state hospital has very new
hampshire hospital has very much a
blended management team we have
many senior executives but like the
chief medical officer the chief quality
officer both are dartmouth employees
along with multiple others and we blend
those two leadership teams together to
to provide operational excellence at new
hampshire hospital
the the reason for having a leadership
team at hampstead hospital is because
there is a need to have
accountability to more than just that
physical hospital
that hospital is one part of a
children's system of care so the kids
sitting in emergency rooms the kids
waiting for residential placement all of
the kids that are within the children's
system of care is linked to the state's
children's system of care which is why
we want state employees leading that
hospital so that the strategy is not
just about operating that 70 or 80 beds
the strategy of that hospital is how it
impacts the entire children's system of
care
so the ceo the ceo the cfo
those are strategy positions the
day-to-day operations the third party
the third party contractor will have a
hospital administrator there who links
and blends with this leadership team but
the leadership team is a strategy team
the ceo the ceo that's the role that
they play in any hospital management
team
their strategy is to create a a campus
of excellence a center of excellence to
link with the entire system of care for
children's behavioral health
we're going to try this for two years if
if we in the next two years find that
there are certain positions that should
be contracted and not state employees
then we will do the rfp that way
what we do know is the finance team will
never be contracted there is no private
entity in this state or nationally that
could figure out state financing uh it
has it has to be as state employees
right so when you pull the finance part
out you have the ceo the ceo compliance
officer because
it's a state-owned building and we need
to maintain joint commission compliance
in order to continue to bill
general counsel again with same with
finance the legal system within state
government needs to be state employees
so
in any other contract we we also see
this type of structure in some of our it
departments when it comes to mmis and
bridges where we have deloitte
being a main contractor having a lot of
the on frontline employees and then
having state employees supplementing it
we see that in other areas
so it's not completely unheard of
representative rose sorry senator
rosenwald thank you madam chair so
um
i've been supportive of the state
acquiring hampstead but my understanding
i think like some other peoples was that
after the very short term we were
looking at hiring state employees like
we do
at new hampshire hospital and glencliff
for example does this mean that
the department might consider
changing
glencliff for example from a state
employee-driven
workforce to outside vendors i'm just
i'm not sure
why the state
would want to own it if we don't want to
run it with our own people that we hire
and train and because we can't we're
we're not market rate with our wages so
one of the reasons why commissioner
erlinghousen is is here in front of you
asking for recruiters is our wage scale
does not allow us to
to recruit people at the level of skill
that we need and
i mean that is why new hampshire
hospital has a 38 vacancy rate for
nurses right now it's why glencliff is
running at about 80 out of 120 for
census because we can't attract staff up
there
our wages are just not competitive a
third party can
pay wages that are competitive with the
marketplace so it makes sense for
hampstead going into a new contract that
they absorb the direct care workers the
nurses the social workers the mental
health counselors under their contract
so that they can pay a competitive wage
do i think that the state at some point
could
fix the wage scale to pay a competitive
wage yes but i think that is a very long
process i think that's going to take
years
and we are
going to be running hampstead in the
next three months
follow up please follow up so on top of
the competitive wages that the outside
vendor has to pay they're presumably
going to want to make some profit as
well
should we not expect that
that model is going to be more expensive
down the road than
having a state
owned and operated
facility
the no
i would i would say that if you look at
new hampshire hospital and glencliff and
you compare it to
to comparative facilities new hampshire
hospital to other hospitals glencliff to
other nursing homes that they're
probably some of the most expensive
facilities to run
because of the cost of state employee
benefits
overall state run
i would say that
it costs more to run a state-run
hospital or a state-run nursing home
than a private nursing home or a private
hospital
thank you
are there further questions uh
representative leishman
thanks madam chair and this
this question is as a result of your
response to senator rosenwald
now you said there's a 33 percent
vacancy rate at new hampshire hospital
how is
a contractor coming in that as
representative roosevelt pointed out
will need a profit
how are they going to find a competitive
or a good work force if they've got to
provide a profit and provide
such a rate or contract with you that's
competitive they are hiring the current
staff at hampstead and increasing their
wages to be competitive so
there's that um so the hampstead is
staffed to run 45 45-bit hospital right
now so they will be offering employment
to all of those staff so their current
their current staff they also have
national connections where they can
recruit out of state and bring in state
which is what we're wanting them to do
we plan to
increase the capacity at hampstead
slowly but over the next two years to
include a prtf to include other acute
units they have a 12 bed
adult unit now they have the remaining
beds being children but they're also
running an iop intensive outpatient
program a partial program and other
programs that we may or may not continue
to run and then we would absorb those
staff into the rest of the hospital beds
we really need to get in and evaluate it
are there any further questions
i do have one
i assume that currently hempstead
hospital has all of these people
okay yeah
i wouldn't say all of them but several
of them and several of them are
candidates to come over to be state
employees i mean they may not have a
contract manager i i i guess no but
several people on their leadership team
has expressed interest in coming into
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
madam chair i'll move to table
uh
representative leishman moves to table
do i have a second
second
roll problem to table zero eight three
uh clerk votes no
representative erf no
representative leishman yes
representative lynn
now
senator daniels yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro
representing hamburger no
madam chair the vote is two yes and
eight no one tabling okay madam chief
the
the vote to table fails
uh on a two in favor and eight opposed
senator morris yeah madam chair i'm
gonna move the item but i'm also gonna
uh caution everybody um we need to know
more what's going on on that campus
um i think we need to understand where
we're headed here as a state
i'll move the item because i think the
operational side i understand already
but i think before we go any further
with where we're taking plans in the
state i think the fiscal needs to
understand that and especially if this
is going to be decisions made
when we get out of here in may
i think we
need to set some kind of system up where
fiscal's being briefed on it so
i moved the item every second but can i
may i also make a comment just
of course sort of follow up on what
senator moore said i i guess i i you
know the one thing that leads me
led me to vote not to table was your
statement that we're going to sort of
see how this goes for a couple of years
and if we have to make some changes
um that i i
i think that's very important that that
happened and i i guess i'm you know i'm
i'm i'm sort of
inclined to defer to what you say you
are sort of the experts in this area i'm
sort of inclined to defer but
i i'm not sure candidly that i've gotten
a really satisfactory explanation for
why
it wouldn't be appropriate to just have
you know one contract administrator
for this for this operation
and
everyone else be uh subject to to the
a contract administrator that's a state
employee and everyone else be subject to
the contract and presume you know you
say you want to make sure that people
are all sort of on board following the
state's plan and all of that makes
perfect sense to me but
why can't
a why couldn't a contract administrator
ensure that
all the people that are working under
the contract are on
are you know on the on the same page so
to speak so as i say maybe maybe there
are reasons why it makes more sense to
do this i'm willing to defer but i'm i i
sort of share the same concerns that
senator moore says
thank you
okay senator gaiden thank you madam
chair i would i would echo um
representative lin's comments
uh i've had some experience with federal
contracts multi-billion dollar contracts
under the auspices of a single contract
administrator with very very clearly
defined
and omnipotent authority to challenge
any deficiencies or potential defects in
performance
and so rather than establishing an
entire staff i'd like to look towards a
contract administrator model
and and given credence of course your
comments that we have three months to
representative emerick thank you madam
chair
one of the things that's come out of
several different dialogues we've had
this morning
indicates that we're
understaffed
and i think we we don't really have an
opportunity loss or an opportunity costs
associated with vacancies you
highlighted that in the new hampshire
hospital you can only have so many beds
because you just can't staff it so what
that's saying is we are not we're not
fulfilling our mission as a state
because we can't kiss and i'm not i'm
not looking at you and saying you're
doing a bad job i'm saying you've
highlighted a reality that if we don't
do something about staffing we are going
to be deficient as a state fulfilling
our mission to our citizens so i'm i'm
just throwing that out there as a
rhetorical comment not directed
necessarily at you but just that all of
the vacancies that we're talking about
thank you for that comment and and i'd
like to point out that
every
every program that the department
oversees whether it's state employee run
or not
is having workforce issues so every
program we want to put forward we can we
can have the best ideas on how to solve
the substance use disorder crisis the
mental health crisis but if our partners
in the community also cannot hire people
then
it sets us up for failure
so it really is a workforce issue across
the state and in some areas it is the
type of work we do when it when it's
mental health and substance use or the
um
the high clinical licensure required and
in some cases it's it for the state
employees it's it's things like wages so
i think every employer has different
challenges
yes
commissioner the um you mentioned you're
going to be in three months operating
which
i
that's good news so that means that your
deal is going to be signed
um
at that point will you have
the ability to talk to us about
this concept that you're working on
yes so we're expecting our close date
for hampstead hospital to be april may
and then a third party to come in right
after that along with this team to to
operate the hospital for the next two
years this summer we will enter into
drafting an rfp for a long term how the
hospital would be would be run we will
take what we learn from from the next
year or so of operations and incorporate
that into the rfp for going forward but
right now it's it's the short term right
we don't we don't have the luxury of
time to really um sit down and make a
decision
who's the contract administrator would
be a great example because the decisions
made in a hospital are very clinical
decisions so does our contract
administrator need to be a doctor a
psychiatrist a nurse
a business person all of those things
need to be fettered out over the next
several months and then we'll be in the
rfp once we're running the hospital when
we talk about what it what's our plan
for
the the the campus of excellence or the
center of excellence what else is going
to happen at hampstead hospital as we
build out the beds i think there is the
opportunity to have a larger discussion
about that um spring into summer for
sure which is where i think the
legislature needs to weigh in
because we're talking about a campus and
those ideas i don't think have been
vetted with the legislature right now
i think it would be beneficial in may
because we'll be leaving right after
that to come back and have a larger
discussion
about this um you'll certainly be on the
operational phase by that and and i
think one point
and this is
in your favor that i think
overall what we've been trying to do and
i gave it a plug a little while ago but
i'll give it again
we we are going to a company that can
bring employees into new hampshire when
we looked at epping we were going to an
employee they could bring people into
new hampshire we're not going to solve
this unless we get creative like that
and i think that's an important part of
this i think it's a little surprise on
the management side but
that's why maybe if you get in there in
may we can go through all this
yeah i think i think we've made the
determination you know at the department
that solving several of the issues
workforce included mental health
substance abuse is going to take public
private partnerships and that's what
this is that's what the epping project
is it's really that public private so
that
we have leverage on how our system our
overall system operates and how that one
piece fits into our system but on on the
private side they get to pay the wages
and have more operational efficiency
than a state-run facility
are there any further comments yes
representative leishman thanks madam
chair and i see senator moore staring at
me so i'll keep it short
um
so i'm concerned like senator morris
about the cost and the long-term
implication on the state you know arpa
funds were using 1.7 million dollars for
these six positions out of the 15
million that we took back in october
this money is going to run out and this
is going to be a state responsibility
and i'm very concerned
that we have absolutely no idea of the
cost and the amount of people necessary
to run this position and i will support
senator morris's motion but i'm like
others very concerned we have not seen
the information i think we need to see
moving forward
thanks
madam chair uh yes senator mars yeah and
i'm well aware of what we left on the
balance on the 15 million so i thought
about that before i looked at this
but
i think the reality is if you look at
hampstead hospital and this is why we
should talk about this in may
they're not just serving new hampshire
right now
they have clients outside of our state
um
and they're billing
so you're creating a system here and i
guess that's what i want to see what the
intent is if that's
a for-profit setup
manage the state's managing the
for-profit business
there's a lot to look at there i mean
you know what are we currently writing
to hampstead hospital as a state did we
fund them at all you know um and then
what's the income going to be on if you
take it from 50 beds and turn it into 75
and then
other services you know so i think
there's a lot to look at in that whole
concept thing um it could all be very
good to be honest with you um but i also
want to understand what else is going to
happen so thank you
are there any further comments i would
just comment on sender's uh
statement because i think
it's looking like a business enterprise
like the liquor commission
to some extent
you know
and i'm not trying to
equate the two i'm just saying as a
business enterprise it may be a better
structure than trying to take the state
structure and the contract structure and
work it together just say okay
it's it does its own thing so to speak
and makes its own profit
senator d'alessandro thank you
i i think it provides an opportunity for
the state
i think it provides an opportunity
and it's it's uh look at i we did this
once before when we de-institutionalized
it created an opportunity it was okay we
started and then we led up on it and
didn't didn't
fill fulfill our obligations
this is an opportunity we currently have
a contract with with hampstead hospital
what how many how many beds have we
contracted for now
um we don't have a certain number of
beds but we're contracted to provide all
children behavioral health inpatient
services right so we have a contract
that exists now so we have an
opportunity here to provide a
desperately needed system and to do it
properly
and i think coming back he let us
letting us know what the final operation
looks like is is very important i've
been down this road before
i was here
and
i saw
success
and then failure now i'd like to see
okay are there any other
comments
seeing none uh will the clerk call the
role roll call on zero eight three
clerk votes yes representative erf yes
representative leischman yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
no
senator morse yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
fis-22083
passes on a vote of nine to one
which is
uh this is uh authorize
hhs to accept and expend
in
in rescue money
and this is for
wage enhancements
for licensed nursing assistants at
glencliff home
are there any questions
yes uh rep senator rosenwald thank you
madam chair i noticed this is a 16-week
wage enhancement do you expect to be
back
after that to request more funding for
this program
good morning for the record my name is
joe christie i'm the cfo for new
hampshire hospital and glenn cliff
we made it a 16-week program um
i guess by way of background so in the
fall
most nursing homes received a portion of
funding arpa funding and a lot of them
have used that for similar kind of wage
enhancement programs glencliff was not a
part of that at that time but we did
approach gopher to request the
additional funding
and so what we were uh
provided or assuming it passes today
what we will be provided uh is the uh
dollar amount that was uh equal per
i believe it was bed as any other
nursing home facility in the state
so to try to structure
knowing that we have kind of that finite
amount of money to try to structure
something that was meaningful to our
lnas to try to stabilize our staffing
we
identified a 16-week program would allow
us to pay a rate
that that would be meaningful for those
individuals so that's kind of how we
got to the 16-week time frame we are
hopeful that that 16 weeks will carry us
into the summer where covid
we have seen eases up a little bit
and we're hopeful that
that helps with some of our staff
satisfaction and
kind of workload that they're carrying
today
are there further questions senator
guida thank you madam chair can you
comment on the census at glencliff as
opposed to its full capacity
thanks um we're we're running right
around 80 right now between 75 and 80
total capacity is 119
so
running quite a bit below capacity for a
variety of reasons
we have leaned on our other nursing
homes to take people with mental illness
into their communities
we don't believe that that the elderly
that suffer
mental illness need to go to war in new
hampshire to get services we believe
that they should be able to get services
in any nursing home across the state
so we have been working with nursing
homes to open up additional behavioral
health beds in local nursing homes
in addition to that the staffing issue
has created uh an issue for
for maintaining it at full census so
allowing so dropping it down to a point
where we could close off a unit and
reallocate the staff
further further questions let's follow
up thank you
commissioner so safe to say that the
decreased census is due to the shortage
of personnel
primarily it is both it it is both the
the shortage of personnel and it is um
our attempts to move men uh people with
mental illness that are seniors into the
community
for sure this
this enhancement itself just equalizes
the playing field we've given this money
to every other nursing home in the state
to enhance wages for their employees
glencliff was not given the same
enhancement as nursing homes so all of
the the nursing homes around glencliff
are pulling from their staff from them
because they're offering incentives that
further questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
thank you senator d'alessandro second
seconded by senator guida
would the clerk please call the roll
roll call on zero eight four
clerk votes yes
representative irf yes representative
leishman yes representative lynn
yes
senator daniels no
senator morris
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
uh the vote on fis 22-084
is nine in favor one opposed
that it passes
our
the governor's office for emergency
relief and recovery
authorization to expect accept and
expend
30 million
200 or sorry 30 million 32
500 and three dollars
in
federal in arpa
money for
are there any
yes
senator morris yeah is this direct money
i guess my bigger question is it's not
part of the 990
okay
no senator uh
taylor caswell again uh no this is under
the uh emergency rental relief program
it's separate from the fiscal recovery
fund
thank you
uh senator d'alessandro
thank you madam chair uh
there have been some real concerns about
how quickly this is getting out and i
know
people are working overtime but double
time to to get it out and taylor what it
what is the
what is the main problem is it the
paperwork is it i mean is it that what
it is there's a paper log gm
in terms of it i know that the community
action programs are basically given the
responsibility of moving this stuff out
the door they've done a pretty good job
but what is the basic the the basic
problem
yeah uh senator we i all your points are
well taken we've been reducing
new hampshire housing finance authority
has really been sort of uh spearheading
this effort with the caps uh they they
have it's a very hand-holding sort of
experience that you have to get through
for each applicant
in order to get
you know through the eligibility
component and get the money to them
the time that it takes for them to
process this entire process has been
going down as we've gone along here um
as far as the specific like exact
reasons why
i can't really speak to that
specifically but we do watch that
category from the gopher side i would
say broadly though the funding that
we're talking about here is a late item
because we only got this resource
dropped into the state accounts last
friday so we want to move that over to
them so that that's not standing in the
way of any further
delays that you're referring to
thank you thank you senator rosenwald
thank you
how many um
families
are you participating this
30 million dollars is going to help and
what for how long
what kind of scope
overall at this point under
if you take both era 1 and era 2
there have been a little over 13 000
households that have been assisted thus
far
and the average amount of that
assistance is just under eight thousand
dollars
so that's the scope this continues
representative leitchman
thanks madam chair nice to see you
commissioner i guess i could call you
the uh our bazaar perhaps could you
could you tell us you know we see these
requests coming in you just mentioned
this came in like last friday or
whatever
is there more out there is this getting
close to that's it there's still more
left yeah so we expect to have
the ability to see another toronto
funding under this particular program
sometime in the next couple resources in
order to continue to see the funding hit
our accounts but once it does hit our
accounts we amend the contract and then
send that money over to nif and have
them continue to run the program
thank you thank you madam chair are
seeing none could i have america oh i'm
sorry senator guy excuse me thank you um
can you comment on the eligibility
requirements to participate in this or
maybe maybe ben might be able to better
do i don't know for the the rental
program yes yeah i mean if ben wants to
talk or rob wants to talk a little bit
to that they could probably give you
good afternoon senator thank you for the
question
for the record my name is rob daphis i'm
the executive director of new hampshire
housing finance authority so the
emergency rental assistance program was
established by congress with
income and eligibility limits the income
limit is 80 of area median income
for where the applicant resides and then
there are also eligibility
requirements associated with
the hardship that the applicant must
have experienced during the coveted
period and the eligibility the hardship
the specifics of that hardship
requirement are a little bit different
between era 1 and era 2.
this funding request is for the era 2
funds which are a little bit more
flexible somebody must have experienced
a significant
loss of income or increase in expenses
during the period of the coveted
pandemic
do you have a follow-up thank you so my
presumption is then
that they would have to provide some
evidence
of covid causation to be eligible we're
not just distributing money to people
that want it
so that was a specific requirement of
era one was that there would be a
coveted uh
a direct relationship between the
coveted pandemic and the uh and the
hardship that the person experienced
it's not quite as direct a relationship
that's required under er a2 and so
somebody has to self-attest that they
experienced a hardship but they don't
have to necessarily draw the connection
between the coveted pandemic in a lot of
cases this is related to something like
increased household costs
associated with increased gas prices or
food heating utility prices and things
like that anybody can get it
okay uh
representative emrick thank you madam
chair
you you dropped a number out there of 13
are currently in the program or have
taken advantage of the program 13 000
households that have been assisted or
are currently being assisted that's one
percent of the population
so it's uh households as opposed to
individuals
so it's even greater
that's right wow okay
that was how many
do you have a backlog
so there there are uh several thousand
applications that are currently pending
that the cap agencies have received that
they haven't completed processing and
determined their eligibility uh that's
uh about 4700 applications at the
present time now some of those are
applications from households that have
already been assisted so it's not
necessarily another 5 000 households
that are going to be assisted because
you can only apply for a certain amount
of assistance at a time so
follow up
so using kentucky windage of how many
individuals per household blah blah blah
we could be talking about three percent
of the population
50 percent of the households of of the
state i'm i'm not trying to pin you down
i'm just saying this is a bigger number
than
i had envisioned or i could anticipate
yes i think it's certainly more than one
percent and it
may be as high as three percent of the
population it's been assisted in some
way uh through this program thank you
thank you madam chair
and this is just rental assistance
correct this is not mortgage assistance
it's not mortgage assistance it's rental
assistance and utilities and associated
costs
senator guida thank you ma'am sure did
this program exist pre-pandemic
are there any further questions
thank you uh could i have a motion
please
thank you senator d'allesandro do i have
a second
all right uh
representative emrick seconds
would the clerk please call the roll
roll call zero eight six
clerk votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative senator daniels yes
senator morse
senator gaida
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative hamburger yes
madam chair the vote is nine to one
22086 passes on a vote of nine to one
thank you very much
uh commissioner caswell
we're not letting you go
okay i was trying to i wasn't trying to
sneak out yeah i saw that i saw i saw
that
um
we had asked uh the commissioner to uh
come to us with uh
to
provide a
cares funding update which uh
which we got this morning
and um and we thank you for that
and uh next month he will be here to
talk about where we stand on uh our
money
so
i will
turn it over to you
certainly i'm happy to do it and uh
thank you uh madam chairwoman so i
wanted to walk through a couple of
things uh with regard to the background
of cares act
you should have documents in front of
you that give you
the outline of the programs that were
included under cares act
so a couple of things i'm going to talk
about sort of the background of this
what we've the usage that we
that we saw as a result of the
programming a little bit about how we
run the process or how we ran those
programs
at uh at gopher
and then
just sort of where we are with keras
right now
so if you go all the way back to march
13th of 2020 that's when the governor
declared the state of emergency and the
cares act was actually signed a law into
law shortly thereafter on i believe was
march 27th
um we established gopher on april 14th
of 2020
and immediately
those resources started coming to the
state and a number of programs were
designed initiated and executed and
deployed pretty quickly because we had
the main street relief fund which was
our first
uh program that was designed to assist
small businesses around the state
that launched on may 15th of 2020
and in the end that fund ended up
providing resources to the tune of
around 400 million dollars
to state employers
subsequently by july 17
a good almost a billion dollars worth of
that cares act funding that we had
received
was obligated
and started to move out the door pretty
quickly and this was
very much by design time
we wanted to
make sure that these immediate relief
funds were treated as such and were out
to
the people that needed it as quickly as
we could get it
i do think it's worth noting as well
that the speed to which we were able to
move those funds enabled a lot of
businesses to keep their doors open a
lot of people could stay employed
through some of the depth of the
pandemic
in the summer and fall of 2020
and did line us up quite nicely as we
started to see our unemployment rate go
from sixteen percent at the height uh
right down into three percent uh in
january and february of 2021.
uh so uh and that was uh at a pace
that uh exceeded other states in this
part of the country
if we look then continuing on we had the
deadline original deadline for cares act
as you will recall was
december of 2020
on december 27th of 2020 the federal
government changed the deadline and
pushed it out for a year
which did throw a couple of programs
into
uh you know it enabled us to extend the
life of several programs
and to recycle some of those resources
over the course of 2021.
in june 2021 the state of emergency
expired
and
and then we went on from there i would
say in between there i would note as
well there was
a
in the april time frame we did require
those businesses that had received main
street funds
to submit their reports to us into dra
at which time
we were also told that
some of those funds if they were not
directly attributable to
revenue
losses
during that period of time that there
would be a need to recoup some of those
funds from some of those businesses
at which point that we
we launched a new program that allowed
businesses
to take covert related expenses from
and apply them to to the potential
recruitment amount that they were facing
uh under that chain under that provision
and subsequently reduced the recruitment
load pretty significantly uh for
businesses around the state i would add
that we additionally added a program
near the end of 2021 that that further
gave further opportunity for businesses
to reduce that amount by with a coveted
expense program that allowed them to be
reimbursed for covert related expenses
through for almost the entire year of
2021. so
uh
that
extension of time that we had
experienced in
december of 2020
really did allow us to go back and make
sure that we recycled those funds back
into
um
just in general
of course the total amount that we were
provided by the feds under care act
cares act was 1.25 billion dollars
at this point we have expended an
obligated 1.18 billion dollars
we fully expect by the time that we're
done with the program later this fall
that we will have expended every every
cent of that 1.25 billion dollars
over the course of the life of cares act
there were around 70 individual relief
programs that were initiated and over 15
recipients of funding under the program
and as i pointed out
a good portion of that roughly about
half of those funds were related to
employer relief and i i would i would
point out that the employer relief
component of that was not exclusively
for profits
we also provided a number of programs
for non-profit employers including a
program called the nerf program
that i think totaled around 41 million
dollars that was
basically a copy of the main street
program that allowed
those non-profits to also benefit as
employers
from those resources we also had
programs for hotels and for lodging
operations performing arts
uh and restaurants
as we went through that process
the second largest uh component of
resources you know if you take them in
big buckets was really in the health
care space
all total on the cares act that was
around 236 million dollars
those were for things like hospitals
support direct hospital support
long-term care facilities and
stabilization
mental health facilities and
substance use disorder
programming
i wanted to spend just a quick moment on
how this process
sort of operated behind the scenes
because it is one thing to be able to
get the funding
approved and to move forward it's
another thing to operationalize this
number of programs
and
you know while i came to gopher
in september of 2021
there was a lot of action that had
already taken place under
jerry little's uh
role in the sa in the same role that i
had in the staff
some of whom are still with us on the
gopher side put in
extremely long hours in
getting these programs up and running
we would go through a whole process of
making sure that everything that we were
proposing all of the provisions of the
program
met the eligibility requirements of
cares act we would have to go through a
process just for example on the main
street fund alone of designing an
application uh we that that we tried to
keep that as short as we possibly could
it went through a whole process of
making sure that we were not
requiring anything that was not
absolutely necessary to run the program
or to report on that program later on
that all had to be developed and put
online
uh tested extensively and then used by
tens of thousands of businesses
and then once those applications were
reviewed we had to
receive we had to review all of those
applications and once again work with
those businesses and individual
organizations to make sure that what
they were requesting met the
requirements
our whole attitude throughout this
entire period was to get this money into
the hands of the recipients with his
little with his little
you know bureaucracy so to speak as
necessary
and to really continue to recognize as i
mentioned that these funds were relief
funds and we treated them as such and
tried to get them out the door as
quickly as possible but there's a lot of
businesses had individual circumstances
had individual situations uh that needed
literally a lot of hand-holding from our
staff and also from the department of
revenue administration which was very
central to at least that particular
program
then we get to the point of awards a lot
of these programs had literal paper
checks that had to go out uh that's
where our uh our friends at dis really
sort of
stepped up and enabled us to move those
those funds quickly and to get the
checks out uh
the behind the scenes uh you know
getting addresses and that sort of thing
from dr from us to dra to das and this
whole process was
took a lot of time uh but it did
actually work and and the results as
i've stated were pretty good
now we're very much in the in the
monitoring
standpoint uh and finishing up and
getting those reports done there's a
couple of programs as you know that we
did a little switcheroo at the end of
2021 when they allowed us to put some
types of programs
into cares act from arpa
those programs are
wrapping up the recoupment components
are wrapping up
and we're getting to the point now where
we're able to get a clear vision as to
what the numbers are looking like
and i would say you know the biggest one
that we're watching is the waterfall
amount as you know at the end of the
fund once all of the cares act programs
and everything has been said and done
and accounted for anything that's
remaining
would waterfall into the state's
unemployment trust fund
and at this point we're roughly
estimating that to be somewhere between
45 and 70 million dollars
once we get to the end of
this whole process and
my friend chase here spends a lot of
late nights reporting to
treasury and gathering information from
the different agencies and from so on
and so forth
to make sure that that all occurs so
i guess that's the quick overview i know
of a process that many of you were
involved in through the legislative
advisory board and some of the
stakeholder boards that were occurred
under the state of emergency uh and
again it's just sort of a snapshot and
again we'll i think we're planning to
come back and be here again and at your
march meeting and
give a similar update on where we are
with the arpa funds so
i think i can stop that there and
certainly happy to talk about or answer
any questions that anybody might have
yes senator guida very quickly madam
chair thank you uh commissioner taylor
for your uh
uh for your testimony i note that your
hair wants blonde is now gray
thank you for noticing senator and with
that i would i would ask is there any
kind of an audit function of these funds
you know spot audits for
for the integrity of applicants and
things like that absolutely that's a
good point i neglected to mention that
particularly under
the larger programs we absolutely
perform spot audits and we're still
doing that
yes senator daniels thank you would you
expect that the amount that you'll be
left over in the waterfall going to
employment security would be enough to
trigger a decrease in rates for
employers
uh
as i recall
there is a threshold that we are trying
to meet
with that category and to also stay
under because i think we changed that
didn't we
do you want to explain
that
uh chase hageman deputy director at uh
gopher it's probably a better question
for nhes but we have had conversations
about um making you know ensuring that
uh the timelines are appropriate in
terms of meeting any thresholds and
triggering any any rate cuts or
increases um
and i i believe the
the amount that we're talking about
should not
at least in loot in in preliminary
conversations not cause any problems
basically is really the short answer
uh
representative leishman
thanks many chair and commissioner this
report was very helpful and uh do you
share my concerns because i look at
these
a number of the recipients like veterans
programs homelessness
all good causes when this money
is completely gone
are we going to see a very negative
impact on some of these programs that we
helped create or support or are my
concerns like misguided
that's a good point representation i
mean we sort of refer to that issue as
the prime directive at gopher just said
jokingly i guess but
um
the idea of making these investments is
as as one time as we possibly can make
them
has been um
you know certain part of the culture
throughout we have not we've been very
sensitive to the fact
that as you point out there are
potentially instances where the
emergency and the nature of the
emergency created a need an immediate
need in the in the
to benefit the public to make
investments
um
uh in in more than one yes
it's sort of operational management type
my hope is that those can trigger
institutional changes
in those networks where we had to make
those investments to avoid the issue of
setting up basically a cliff where we
have made investments that are going to
carry an institution or an organization
out to a certain point and then the
money drops and away it goes so
we have had the uh i would say in most
instances what you're seeing in the
programs particularly under arpa cares
act was a little bit different in the
sense that it was an emergency situation
but we've been very sensitive to
minimizing that type those types of
investments thank you thank you madam
chair
i'd i'd really like to thank you for
bringing this information i think it's a
it's an excellent summary that all of us
i think knew
little parts and pieces of but
didn't have the the full um the full
picture of
what
i can't even say that money uh what the
yes i can
only because when i was in the air force
we'd say oh well it's a billion here and
a billionaire what difference does it
make you should have my job
representation yeah i should
[Laughter]
but anyhow i i really do um
thank you for this it's a it's a great
it's a great summary document so
thank you happy to do it thank you i
appreciate it and we'll look we'll look
forward to seeing you in march
as well
are there uh any questions on
that hhs
has so graciously
okay
seeing none
um
i will now move to
our audits
now i want you to notice that it says we
were supposed to on the schedule audits
were supposed to start at 10 30.
okay just just so you know
and i apologize for um
i apologize for all the questions we had
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee for the record steve smith
director of audits for the lba
the first uh first audit is the college
savings plans which is two components
the unique and the fidelity advisor
joining us from pwc who's under contract
with with us in our office
is declan byrne he's the
partner but before he begins uh monica
mezzoparolo state treasurer would like
to make a few comments related to the
just just make sure the microphone is
okay good thank you perfect
uh good morning madam chair oh good
afternoon um chair members of the
committee for the record um monica mr
pele's state treasurer and trustee of
the 529 plan
so first of all i would like to thank
mr byrne and
his team at pwc and
director steve smith for the
collaboration and completing this audit
uh again timely and with excellent
results
um so
before i turn it over to mr burn i just
quickly would like to
provide you with a few highlights um as
i recently mentioned
uh to you um the fighter amp the new
hampshire fighting plan has been again
very successful uh this year
it continues to provide um
it continues to benefit many uh new
hampshire families and many families
throughout the country to provide the
benefits to help them save for the
ultimate goal to to save for
post-secondary education
the new hampshire plan
remains the
fourth largest in the country
with
approximately 23 billion dollars in
the plan has about
over 800 000
accounts
and
and you had a very successful year over
the past year um the plan uh grew
approximately i don't know i don't have
sixteen percent
and that can be attributed to uh again
the performance of the um the excellent
performance of the capital markets but
also uh due to the contributions from a
program manager federal investments that
continue their efforts to increase new
accounts
and
increase contributions as this plan
continues to mature and more families
use these funds to withdraw them for for
the college expenses
uh again the the plan continues with a
what a steady growth
um
as you also know um the state also
benefits from the
administrative assessment that is
charged to 59 participants and again the
state
and fiscal year 21 receive approximately
17.7 million and with those
with those funds
the state was able to provide about 7
000 scholarships to
low-income new hampshire students so
again another successful year there
the scholarships that were provided went
between were ranged between
1 000 and 11 000 for for families for
students
so again another successful year so we
hope that this strength continues in
many years to come so with that i will
turn it over to mr burns for the actual
audit results
perfect thanks a lot and it's great to
be here in person and for the record i'm
declan byrne the other partner
responsible for the audits for pwc for
the 529 plans here in new hampshire it
is great to be here in person and it's
been a been a two years since we
presented these results in person and
it's one of the highlights of the year
for me come here and present the results
and we did provide our materials in
advance maybe i'll refer to page six
which which is the substantive areas of
our of our audit which we executed as of
9 30 year-round
and as monica said it was a very
successful audit no major findings as
part of this year's year's audit we
we've signed off our ordered opinion on
december 20th
that was pretty consistent with prior
year pretty consistent with where we
planned and our designed our procedures
uh did not have to substantially change
during the course of the audit that's a
reflection of the good support we got
from both fidelity the administrator as
well as monacan team as we work through
our audits through october november and
december so pretty standard good results
with a lot of our team work from home
but that is the new normal and my
highlight on some of the pages here some
of the report reportable items and
there's not a lot significant of a
negative manner to report and we did not
find any significant deficiencies
material weaknesses fraud legal acts
anything in the control environment
worthy of your attention
we rely significantly on the on the
audits of the
internal controls of fidelity at the
provider they they house the books and
records and we spend a lot of time with
that organization understanding their
control environment and making sure
they're accurately recording the
existence valuation and dda plan
expenses that are in the plan
we didn't find any exceptions we'd have
no unrecorded misstatements or record
misstatements so i would say it was a
very smooth
uh well-organized audit and we released
on time so our team could go off and
have their christmas break
um
in terms of our other areas of focus in
the order that's fraud we certainly tend
to mix up our procedures every year from
an unpredictable predictably standpoint
uh testing
material items just to keep fidelity on
their toes
no exceptions noted we also do fraud
inquiries with
members of management and nothing came
to our attention um from a fraud or
legal acts perspective
now the other parts of our report covers
our required communications and these
are standard under professional
standards and i'd refer to them on asian
10 but really with nothing of
significance that i would actually draw
your attention we have a lot of no
answers here that's a good result
some of the hot major highlights here is
we didn't encounter many difficulties in
the audit the quality of the financial
statements uh
are always in line with professional
standards and we've no major exceptions
as it relates to disclosures
and as i mentioned no no controlled
efficiencies or identified misstatements
so overall as we sit back um we're very
pleased that we signed off on time
great collaboration with management
we're so we're very happy that we're
able to
uh finish on time and in a
well-organized manner so um you know
another successful year behind us and we
thanked the monican team and the
fidelity for being good partners and
giving us all the required support on
time so we're able to effectively uh
finish your audit so
with that um happy to answer any
questions i know our materials have the
other required communications they're
just our standard representation letters
engagement letters that we work with
steve monican team but uh nothing of
note all in line with what you'd expect
and probably seen before
well i'm happy that our 529 account yes
and accounts are in
in good shape it's uh
and yeah and i also didn't realize i
knew that we had a large 529 program but
i didn't realize we were fourth
in the us i think we are we're the
fourth largest in the country yeah um
feel the largest are um virginia nevada
new york
um
we're behind them but okay
that just
yeah that just um
really speaks to the quality of our
our 529 program and
i know this has been going on for years
and years and years and
just just to remind the committee um in
order to comply with sec requirements
you previously approved the release when
available these reports i believe back
in november you yes but so
well i don't want to get it in sec
trouble
i i can get into enough trouble oh sorry
oh
did that covered that covered both you
need yes and 529
yes oh okay
thank you
so the last audit was performed by our
office
joining me is belay skids she's a senior
auto manager
that was in charge of this performance
audit also joining us from
child care unit is beauty chief i
believe is melissa clement
so with that i'll turn over to vlader
present
thank you
good afternoon good afternoon uh good
afternoon madam chair members of the
committee my name is bilay skidz and
this afternoon i'll be presenting the
child care licensing unit or cclu
performance audit report
the purpose of our audit was to
determine whether the cclu's licensing
functions were efficient and effective
during fiscal years 2018 to 2021
and our executive summary starts on page
one
we found the cclu was generally
effective in helping to ensure child
care programs in new hampshire were
compliant with licensing requirements it
was also responsive to the child care
programs it oversaw almost 90 percent of
child care programs responding to our
survey reported cclu staff were
professional knowledgeable fair and
responsive
as shown in our recommendation summary
on page three our report contains eight
observations with recommendations to
increase the cclu's efficiency and
ensure and ensure it continues to
operate effectively
the cclu concurred with all eight
observations require some legislative
action
our first three observations addressed
timeliness
we found the cclu processed initial
permits quickly so that new child care
programs could begin operating as soon
as possible this was consistent with its
priority of ensuring new programs opened
quickly
even during the combat 19 pandemic it
processed permits 12 days faster than
before the pandemic
however it did not always convert
permits to full licenses timely
half of the permits we reviewed were not
converted to full three-year licenses
before the permit expired
additionally less than 20 percent of the
renewal licenses we renewed were
processed within the time limits
established in statute
finally we found the cclu needed to
improve its process to ensure programs
filed their renewal applications timely
but despite these shortcomings programs
remained open to ensure children were
not displaced while the cclu processed
applications
additional management oversight and some
legislative action establishing specific
application processing time frames could
help the cclu be more efficient in
three of our observations numbers four
five and seven
discuss the cclu's oversight of
licensing rules
we found the cclu conducted unannounced
visits to child care programs as
required by federal law in fact 99 of
the programs we reviewed received at
least one unannounced visit each year
however the cclu did not had not
implemented a standardized tool for
licensing coordinators to use when
conducting annual visits risking some
inconsistency although it is working
towards one
the cclu was also effective in ensuring
programs corrected violations of
critical rules before issuing licenses
critical rules were those which were
deemed most likely to jeopardize the
health safety or well-being of children
or the operations of the child care
program itself
however we found the cclu lacked needed
a formal process to monitor the child
care program's correct violations of
non-critical rules as well as a process
to track when corrective action plans
were due
our remaining two observations number
six and eight address improvements to
the background check process and
strengthening data collection to help
management evaluate cclu's performance
our report also contains two other
issues and concerns that did not rise to
the level of an observation but cclu
management may want to consider
these include reviewing the process for
making employment eligibility
determinations for some child care
workers who previously lived outside of
new hampshire
and establishing a process to track the
our report also contains some
information on the state of the child
care industry this chapter starts on
page 11.
in this section we provide a map showing
licensed child care capacity by me by
municipality as of june 30th 2021 the
map shows areas where there are high
concentrations of child licensed child
care spaces in dark blue while areas
where there are no licensed child care
spaces in dark red
you can also see on table 2 on page 13.
excuse me
when you say there are no beds avail no
beds
no spaces available
does that mean they have child care but
it's just not
open
you just don't have slots for people no
that means that there are no licensed
child care facility spaces in that town
so there may be license exempt
facilities which we didn't look at but
those areas in red have no child care
programs
that's very scary
thank you you're welcome
you can also see in table two on page 13
that new hampshire had a net loss in the
number of child care programs of about
three percent each year or total of nine
percent during the entire audit period
however the loss of licensed child care
spaces wasn't as dramatic it wasn't as
drastic
if you look at table 4 on page 15 you'll
see that from fiscal years 2018 to 2019
the state actually had a net gain
in licensed child care spaces the same
was true for fiscal years 2019 to 2020.
the only time period new hampshire had a
net loss in child care spaces was
between fiscal years 2020 and 2021
during the height of the covet 19
pandemic
the actual impact on the number of child
care spaces is still unclear
even though the number of licensed child
care spaces did not change drastically
child care programs
who responded to our survey indicated
they were operating at about 20 percent
below their licensed capacity
as child care supply and demand begin to
stabilize in the state the cclu will
have to continue to review its processes
and adjust its practices
this concludes my presentation i'd like
to thank the cclu staff for their help
during the audit and i'll turn it over
thank you thank you thank you madam
chair members of the committee um i want
to first thank the audit team for their
work i really have appreciated their
collaboration and cooperation as they
come as they came in and requested our
records and reviewed everything and made
these observations we concurred with
everything that they found we recognized
that we do need to strengthen some of
our policies and procedures some of that
is due to the fact that i have worked in
the child care licensing unit for 20
years the supervisors i have under me
have been there 14 years or longer as
has our office staff so much of our
policies and procedures are probably not
written down as well and as clearly as
they should be there it's institutional
knowledge is that we've had because we
have such a long-term staff in our
office so we are definitely working on
remedying that situation we recognize
the need to do that as well and we
certainly look forward to implementing
what has been recommended as we move
forward so we can improve our efficiency
and i'm happy to answer any questions
you have
well it's uh it's very nice to
to see that
child care is not falling apart like we
thought it would be
and maybe it is but we just don't
realize it
yet
with uh you know closers and
get the
percentage but really i thank you for
all of the work that uh that you do in
this and uh i am familiar with uh
your inspections and they're very
thorough and as they should be so are
there any other questions yes
representative emerick
nope you turned yourself off thank you
thank you madam chair
i was stunned when i read this on page
one in the first paragraph it says there
are over 1 000 licensing rules
how can keep anyone keep track of a
thousand rules
so um thank you for that question and
it's a it's an eye opening one i
absolutely understand that when you look
at the child care licensing rules and
how they're laid out
they are laid out are the rules section
is hec
4002 so when you look at any rules in
that section they are often say
hcc 40204
letter a
number one
um roman numeral one so they're broken
up so that they're very specific
so it looks like a thousand rules but
they may have an overall subject such as
the physic the registration form needs
to contain the following items so the
registration form has like 19 items we
require so it's 19 rules so it's it's
still a lot we are working with the new
rule that we have um we have submitted
to um ols and it is under review
hopefully soon by um joint legislative
committee on administrative rules we
have done our best to condense them we
have created more sections but fewer
rules so we are working towards that
we we completely understand it but
that's it was just a stunning number
that's all and some of that just has to
do with how
previous rules when they were written
they were laid out so they were very
specific such as name date of birth
address like that's could be you know 19
rules just for that one registration
form okay thank you sure thank you
are there any further questions
okay thank you very much and thank you
for your continued good work thank you
appreciate it
okay
um
michael hollered at me
so
i'm not going to forget to discuss
when our next meeting is oh that's fine
madam chair uh would just need a motion
to release the audit the performance
audit oh i okay the first two were
already um as steve stated were already
released uh relative to the sec so just
a motion to accept place on file and
release in the ordinary manner
oh okay i'm sorry i didn't i thought we
had released all of these but it's okay
it's okay
uh
jerry and seconded by
senator guida okay senator gaida
uh can i do this and all in favor or do
i okay all in favor please raise your
hand
opposed nine zero
no thank you eight zero
okay okay eight zero
okay
audits
all right
date of next meeting
i don't have a calendar so um the third
friday would be march 18th
um if the committee wanted to stick with
yeah
that's okay i don't drink green beer
um
you know something i forgot to mention
is um
i don't know if any of you have looked
at this streaming youtube video
but there are
closed captions
on the um
on the
screen
and you need to remember to truly
enunciate
very clearly
there are some embarrassing things that
show up
on
the scrolling
so
i should have mentioned that
at the beginning and i didn't but
i will mention it at the end so that
next time we're in a session like this
we will uh
try to remember to enunciate no don't
that way we'll have some good
entertainment yeah
yeah i don't i don't think we need that
all right is there any further business
you